When I first reviewed the 2018 iPad Pro, I
concluded that it was not a computer replacement
liked Apple’s famous “What’s a computer”
ad claimed.
I mentioned that it won’t replace a laptop
until Apple wanted it to, and after spend
two weeks with Apple’s brand new iPadOS,
which is completely separate from iOS, I can
tell you now that you can legitimately replace
your laptop with the new iPad Pro.
Before we get into those changes, let me give
you a quick rundown on what makes the 2018
iPad Pro stand out from the crowd.
It’s the first iPad ever to pack a rounded
display that makes it look unique and modern.
It’s the first iPad ever to have no visible
form of authentication.
Touch ID is gone and there’s no notch for
Face ID, so it seems to unlock magically,
even while it’s upside down.
The new straight-edged design is completely
unique, made to support wireless charging
on the newly updated Apple Pencil, which holds
onto the iPad Pro magnetically for storage,
and packs a new double-tap feature that greatly
boosts productivity.
The new smart keyboard folio is perfectly
sleek and makes it feel like you’re using
a laptop, and if you don’t like it, there
are awesome alternatives from Brydge and Logitech
that work very well.
It packs four high-quality speakers that make
the rest of the iPad lineup sound like Android
tablets, and the display feels buttery smooth
with the ProMotion 120hz technology.
For the downsides, the headphone jack is now
gone, but it’s not a big deal since USB-C
adapters are so cheap on Amazon.
It’s also expensive, starting at $800, but
now that iPadOS is coming, we definitely think
it’s worth it over the other iPads, especially
at Amazon’s sale price of just $700, and
if you’re like me and you wanna make sure
to protect your investment, you have until
60 days after your purchase, or 45 days for
smartphones, to buy an incredibly affordable
warranty from Upsie, our sponsor for this
video.
Upsie works with nationwide certified repair
shops and helps buyers in the United States
save up to 70% on a warranty compared to retailers,
and they make it incredibly easy to make a
claim by having real people available on the
phone, 24/7, 365 days a year, and they store
your receipt and all the info you’ll need,
right in your Upsie account.
And you can use the link in the video description
with the code “MaxTech” today for 10%
off your first warranty purchase.
So back to the iPad Pro, let’s discuss the
awesome new changes coming with iPadOS that
allow you to replace your laptop.
First off, getting USB-C on this iPad Pro
didn’t really mean much since it was so
limited, not allowing you to connect external
drives, but we now finally have external storage
support that works really well!
You can connect anything from a flash drive
to a hard drive or SD card, and transfer various
types of files to the iPad's local storage
folder.
You can even connect multiple drives at once
and transfer files between them.
You can zip and unzip files and folders, And
if you use split-view, you can drag and drop
files directly from a hard drive to an app
like Lumafusion, and it’ll all work without
importing the file to camera roll or the iPad’s
local storage.
We have a full guide to external storage,
which we’ll link to at the end of this video.
Now there’s actually a big list of iPads
that support iPadOS, but the 2018 iPad Pro
and it’s USB-C port is the way to go for
external storage support.
The old Lightning port isn’t able to supply
enough power to be able to drive various storage
drives, so it requires a special camera kit
adapter, which plugs into power, and even
then, some drives still won’t work.
So the convenience of USB-C is well worth
it on the iPad Pro.
One thing that’s pretty amazing is SMB server
support, which works incredibly well, allowing
you to connect to hard drives or servers over
a WiFi connection so you can view and transfer
your archived files.
With iPadOS, you can now open multiple instances
of the same app in split-view, like two notes
apps or two Files apps to make transferring
files easier, and it even works with third-party
apps that support it.
There’s also a bunch of new multitasking
features and gestures that make the iPad much
easier to use, like easier ways to select
text and finally an undo gesture that doesn’t
require you to shake your iPad.
Safari has seen some awesome new updates like
automatic desktop mode that’s optimized
for touch, and there’s a new download manager,
similar to what you get on Mac.
In the settings, you can easily change the
download location to wherever you want.
We were even able to download a powerpoint
file from google and edit it using Keynote.
Perhaps the best part is that iPadOS is getting
exactly the same physical keyboard shortcuts
that we’re used to on macOS, both for use
within Safari and basically everywhere else
on the iPad, so making the switch is much
easier.
And if you’re using the onscreen keyboard,
you’ll be able to pinch it to shrink it
down and move it anywhere you’d like, as
well as use the new swipe keyboard which works
incredibly well.
It’s even better for Apple Pencil users
since input latency has been reduced from
an industry-leading 20ms to a very impressive
9ms.
There’s a new tool palette which can be
easily moved around so it doesn’t get in
your way, and it’s much easier to mark up
a page, just drag from the corner of the screen
using the apple pencil.
From here, you can mark it up and share it,
or tap the Full Page button at the top to
be able to scroll through the entire page.
And you can even grab the scroll bar and scroll
up and down without having to swipe.
And it doesn’t stop there, Apple has finally
added Bluetooth mouse support, but you don’t
actually get a cursor like you do on a Mac,
you’re basically just moving your finger
around and clicking the mouse to perform a
touch gesture, so it’s not the best solution
However, it does fix a huge issue with external
monitor mirroring.
Before, if you use an external display, you’d
still have to touch the iPad to navigate,
but now, you can use a Bluetooth mouse and
keyboard and set your iPad to the side.
Not only that, but if you have a Mac running
macOS Catalina, you can use the iPad as a
secondary display to do things like wirelessly
draw directly into the full macOS photoshop
app using the iPad.
On top of that, the iPad Pro outperforms the
rest of Apple’s latest iPad lineup by a
massive margin, so you’re gonna have no
performance issues in basically any app or
game out there.
I previously stated that people should just
buy the 2019 iPad Air because the iPad Pro’s
performance was so limited due to software,
but I’ve completely changed my mind now
that iPadOS is coming out.
Having USB-C and this level of performance
guarantees the best possible support for apps
and features for years to come, and the unique
design, awesome quad-speakers and new Apple
Pencil make it feel unique and special compared
to the other iPads.
I’d have to say that paying only $700 with
Prime shipping for this iPad Pro, or even
$900 for the 256GB model is well worth the
price, especially if you’re trying to replace
a much more expensive laptop.
I’d definitely recommend anyone looking
at the 2019 iPad Air to just save some more
cash and go for the iPad Pro, because with
iPadOS, it’s finally become what Apple has
envisioned it to be.
If you enjoyed this long-term review, make
sure to hit that like button, click the circle
above to subscribe, and check out one of those
two videos right there.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!